the Treasury Department said remaining
funds from the so-called tarp program
would be focused on helping small
businesses and the housing market herb
allison is the Treasury official
overseeing the program he testifies
before the congressional tarp oversight
panel for about an hour and a half first
time you came to see us you had been in
your office for women and yet already
were full of information and so we're
glad to have you back and hope you'll be
able to update us on tarp as you know
tarp was able to accomplish direct and
immediate help for the largest financial
institutions but small smaller financial
institutions small businesses and
homeowners facing foreclosure have
waited much longer and received much
less help people who funded the bailout
the American taxpayers are bombarded
with news that Wall Street firms that
benefited from tarp with windfall
quarterly profits are now preparing to
reward their executives handsomely with
hefty bonuses that on the other hand
unemployment remains close to ten
percent loan defaults continue to rise
and the foreclosure crisis has no
apparent end in sight I worry not only
because of where we are in this crisis
but that the factors that led us to this
crisis have not yet changed the
financials the financial sector that we
talked about a year ago as to
consolidated too big to fail is more
consolidated than it was back then when
we talked about toxic assets on the
books of the banks those toxic assets
remain on the books of the banks there's
little to inspire confidence in the
balance sheets of the
and the health of small and mid-sized
banks remains a very serious concern
that concern is doubled because they are
truly the lifeblood of small business
lending 99 of these banks have failed so
far as you know and we have more than
400 on the watch list and many are
dangerously overexposed to commercial
real estate we continue to face a grim
picture on regulatory reform the very
rules that will change that will prevent
this crisis from happening again that
process is just starting so I think
taxpayers are concerned about what this
means for their economic security we
hope you can provide some answers today
and put tarp in the proper context and
help us understand where we go from here
the panel's core mission as always is to
ensure that tarp operates with
transparency and accountability we thank
you we thank your staff for working with
us very closely on that and we look
forward to hearing from you today and
now I call on the Deputy Chair Damon
Silver's for an opening statement thank
you gentlemen Warren good morning it's
it's a pleasure again and honored to
welcome you welcome her valosin with us
to be with us I am a very grateful to
your willingness both to appear before
us in these formal settings and the
extent to which you and your staff have
been available to the panel informally
since you arrived at Treasury this
hearing convenes as the office of
financial stability and the Treasury
Department and the administration more
broadly are undertaking a number of
initiatives that appear to be efforts to
respond to concerns raised by among
others this panel regarding the
provision of credit to business
particularly small business the
continued excessive and at least to my
mind somewhat perversely structured
executive compensation at major tarp
recipient institution
and finally as our chair referred to a
moment ago the continued excavation of
the home foreclosure crisis while my
sense of these initiatives is that they
are all directionally correct I look
forward to hearing today about the scope
and design of these initiatives in some
greater detail now I also want to
compliment you assistant secretary
allison on the ofs is handling of the
cancellation of the bank of america acid
guaranty bank of america clearly
benefited from the perception on the
part of the markets that this guarantee
was effectively in place for time and it
was only appropriate that it should pay
a fee for having done so I I don't think
it was a foregone conclusion that that
would in fact occur and I tribute that
to you and your staff leadership and I
think you should you know take some
public credit thank however I remain
extremely concerned that as a result of
having a strategy with the tarp program
that is fundamentally about buying time
in the hopes that the financial asst the
system will earn its way back to health
that we are at risk of a vicious cycle
persistent high unemployment in part
generated by the initial financial
crisis breeds more foreclosures and a
continuing housing depression which in
turn keeps our major financial
institutions week and causes continued
high rates of failures of small banks
weakness in the banking sector then
threatened stacked is a powerful
headwind preventing the revival of
employment outside those firms that can
access the public debt markets we
discussed this matter with Treasury
secretary Geithner when he last appeared
before this panel with this concern in
mind I hope that you'll be able to
discuss with us and with some
specificity the current state and future
prospects of the largest financial
institutions that are continuing
recipients of tarp assistance and I
believe are at the core of the core of
the threat of continued headwinds from
the financial sector those being AIG
Citigroup bank of america and wells
fargo i recognize of course at AIG is a
special case ultimately the wall street
bonuses that get so much attention this
past week make tangible and specific the
growing feeling among the public that we
are back to business
as usual on Wall Street while the
financial system is failing to play its
proper role in supporting the real
economy on Main Street I am interested
in the immediate steps treasury is
taking to counter this perception in
areas like executive pay but the real
test will be whether we really repair
the banking system so that it can
function again or whether we repeat the
unpleasant experience of long-term
economic stagnation Japan went through
in the 1990s again I look forward to
hearing from your testimony this morning
and I again extend my thanks to you for
joining us once again superintendent
Nieman thanks mr. alok thank you very
much for being here today you know more
than anyone how important today's
hearing is to the American public it was
about a year ago that the u.s.
government told the American taxpayer
that the financial system faced possible
collapse if taxpayers did not provide
700 billion to rescue it the taxpayers
did what was asked and they did it even
though it meant swallowing what some
perceive as a very bitter pill I also
don't have to tell you about the
reluctance and in some cases the outrage
of providing financial support to some
of the very institutions that helped
caused the crisis many of which pay
their employees more money in one year
than many Americans make in a lifetime
so the stakes of the effectiveness of
Treasury's use of that seven hundred
billion are very high Treasury's
programs have to work to stabilize the
financial system but they also have to
work so people feel they have also
gained from this massive capital
infusion Treasury's programs must
restore credit for small businesses that
promote entrepreneurship and create jobs
and the program's must keep people in
their homes by preventing avoidable
foreclosures success in these endeavors
goes beyond just restoring confidence in
our financial system success is critical
to maintaining confidence in our
democratic system remembering back to
our first meeting with secretary
Geithner in April I'm glad to say that
we can have a different conversation
today than we had then the Department of
Treasury deserves
for making substantial progress we are
by no means out of this crisis but yours
and secretary Geithner's efforts averted
a disaster and that should be recognized
but our gains remain fragile
particularly as they apply to the people
who need treasuries programs the most as
you and I discussed in our last meeting
together over the summer it is critical
that we redouble our efforts to help the
millions of homeowners facing
foreclosure 'he's i am grateful to the
treasury in to you personally for
participating and arranging the
participants at the hearing last month
in philadelphia it was the first time to
my knowledge that treasury Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac came together in a
public forum with housing advocates and
mortgage lenders to discuss the progress
of the amount of the administration's
foreclosure prevention programs I intend
to follow up on several the issues that
came out of that hearing with you today
I also intend to ask you about improving
access to credit for tens of thousands
of small businesses that employ the vast
majority of our economies workers I'd
like to commend your office and the
administration for announcing
initiatives just yesterday to provide
capital for community banks that are
substantial lenders to small businesses
one year later the financial system
needs to start working better for small
businesses and for all Americans I look
forward to our discussion Thank You
superintendent Neiman a congressman hens
ruling I hope will be able to join us
later and mr. Atkins our fifth panelist
is traveling and not able to be with us
today so that concludes the opening
remarks of the panel mr. Allison I
recognize you for five minutes your
entire written statement will be made
part of the record but but if you could
take a little time no more than five
minutes to bring us up to date I think
that would be helpful thank you very
much chair Warren and members of the
panel thank you for the opportunity to
testify today I welcome this occasion to
update you about the progress we made in
restoring financial stability and to
discuss the impact of tarp programs the
government actions taken last year
including the first phase of tarp are
widely acknowledged as helping to avert
cat
traffic failure of our financial system
when President Obama took office the
financial system was still extremely
fragile and the economy was contracting
rapidly measures taken by the Congress
and this administration have helped
bring stability to our financial system
are assisting responsible homeowners and
are getting credit flowing to consumers
and businesses all at a lower cost to
taxpayers than was anticipated with
these improvements it is time to set a
new direction for tarp we will begin to
wind down and terminate tarp programs
that were launched at the peak of the
financial crisis and cap programs to
purchase legacy assets and to securitize
credit at lower levels than anticipated
now the administration will reshape
targeted assistance to the key
challenges of helping responsible
families keep their homes and helping
small businesses get better access to
credit yesterday President Obama
announced new steps to improve access to
credit for small businesses by providing
lower-cost capital to community banks
small business lending represents
fifty-six percent of business loans from
small banks compared to only twenty one
percent from larger banks there for
community banks with less than 1 billion
dollars in assets will be eligible to
receive new capital at an initial
dividend rate of three percent when
submitting a plan to increase small
business lending the corresponding rate
will be two percent for Community
Development financial institutions in
the coming weeks Treasury will work with
community banks in the small business
community to finalize program terms to
best support small business lending the
other continuing focus will be our
efforts to help responsible homeowners
Treasury's Home Affordable Modification
Program has now provided immediate
relief to more than 500,000 homeowners
who've entered into trial mortgage
modifications families and permanent
modifications are saving over five
hundred dollars a month on average as
this panel noted in its October 9th
report an assessment of foreclosure
mitigation efforts after six months
the panel made a number of findings and
recommendations in that report I've
tried to address them in my written
statement so will only touch on two of
them now first the panel recommended
several areas to improve hamp
effectiveness and transparency Treasury
recently released guidance that
streamlines and standardizes the
paperwork needed for a modification to
make the process more transparent for
borrowers who've been turned down for a
modification we've established the nile
codes that require servicers to report
the reason in writing the treasury and
soon to borrowers as well we're also
improving transparency of the net
present value or NPV model a key
component of eligibility by increasing
public access to the NPV methodology and
encouraging a wider understanding of the
model among housing counselors and
borrowers second the panel recommended
that making home affordable should try
to address a wider population including
borrowers with option arm loans with
negative equity and those who are
unemployed Treasury recognizes that
these situations can be particularly
challenging as the panel's report
reflected our current program does
permit borrowers with pay option arms to
use HAMP when they meet other
eligibility criteria HAMP can also help
homeowners with negative equity to
reduce their mortgage payments to
affordable levels with a hope for
homeowners refinance from the servicer
if the borrower qualifies finally as the
recession deepened unemployment became
an increasing contributor to the ongoing
foreclosure crisis therefore unemployed
borrowers that will receive at least
nine months of unemployment benefits are
eligible for a modification under HAMP
as our efforts progress we will continue
to study ways to meet the challenges of
reducing total foreclosures we're
pleased to be winding down that certain
tarp programs but recognize there are
lingering weaknesses in housing markets
and small business lending we remain
committed to helping American families
and small businesses and building a
broad economic recovery thank you but I
look forward to answering your questions
thank you assistant secretary Allison we
appreciate your remarks I I must say I
am encouraged to hear that Treasury is
talking about winding down large parts
of this program and shifting much of its
focus to foreclosures and small business
lending I will be even happier in the
day when we're put out of business
because this process is complete and
there is no more tarp but let me this
also changes oversight obviously we have
to go where you go so let me focus first
on foreclosure in the foreclosure
mitigation programs if I can I just want
to make sure that we're kind of tracking
here we put the numbers together as you
saw in the report suggesting that the
current mortgage foreclosure mitigation
program or programs when they're fully
operational based on the the most
optimistic assumptions that Treasury has
given us that nonetheless foreclosures
will likely outrun modifications by
about two to one it does that fit with
the numbers you're seeing thanks for the
question chair Warren I think we have to
keep in mind that this program Making
Home Affordable was designed to help
people who are in their primary homes
and these are working Americans we're
not the program was not designed for
second homes or investment homes and so
one has to look at the foreclosure rate
among the eligible population and we
believe we made great strides and at
least today matching the rate of
foreclosures in those or potential
foreclosures in that category with with
trial modifications I understand the
point but surely you're not suggesting
that the half of all people even on the
most optimistic assumptions who are
still going to lose homes are all
investors and and vacation home owners I
understand you've tried to target more
there will still be a substantial number
of homeowners
who will be left out of the program is
that Ryan I just want make sure that
we're dealing with the same set of
numbers here well we are obviously
trying to reach as many people as we can
in this program we are now able to
reduce the debt to income ratios of
people who qualify from above thirty
eight percent all the way down to thirty
one percent so we're reaching a very
large number of people there are some
people who will not qualify for this
program for instance if you have a jumbo
mortgage you don't qualify understand
our people with extremely low incomes
can receive other forms of relief but
this program will be able to serve we
think a very large number of working
Americans who are having trouble staying
in their homes so then let me see if I
can understand this the other way you
give many reasons why there still may be
many foreclosures but if we think of
this problem from a step back
perspective and that is the problem of
dealing with foreclosures in our economy
the impact on neighbors the impact on
communities we can still expect
substantial numbers of foreclosures over
the next few years well actually there
are other measures under way as well
under the arra legislation about 12
billion dollars has been appropriated to
help especially distressed neighborhoods
where many people are at risk of losing
their homes so there are a number of
other programs in addition to the HAMP
program that have been instituted by the
Obama administration to try to deal with
the broader housing crisis that the
country is facing so let me just then if
I can I want to I want to drill in a
little bit on the principal program here
though for homeowners and that is
Treasury has estimated that it will
bring 500 or in fact has announced that
it has brought 500,000 homeowners into
the first program into the HAMP program
now of that 500,000 who are brought in
those are people who just have what are
called temporary modifications that
lasts for only three months what is the
rate at which those people are making it
into what are called
permanent modifications let me first say
that we have extended the trial mod
period up to 60 days for people who are
having difficulty submitting their
paperwork thing and we're doing our best
to streamline the paperwork so that more
people can get through this process and
receive a permanent mud and we are very
glad to see those changes there we are
we are very pleased nice but but the
question is of the 500,000 right how
many are likely to make it into
permanent modifications what are you
what are your numbers so far and what
are your projections well so far the
numbers are low because we're still in
the trial period for most of these
people and it's going to be some months
I'd say sometime in the first quarter of
next year before we have a really good
idea of what the statistically what the
conversion rate seems to be but I
thought I thought they were only in the
trial part for three months so why can't
we tell it on the 91st day how many
people are making it into permanent
modification I mentioned we've actually
extended that trial period for many
people to five months to five all right
so I'll just do the math at 150 first
day why is it that we can't tell what
the permanent yeah the conversion rate
is to permanent modification is there
there are small numbers to date okay we
have about less than 10,000 people who
have moved into permanent modifications
out of the 500,000 because the program
is ramped up rapidly and given the three
to five month delay before they are
given a permanent my butt but point
going forward it can't take you more
than that a couple of months I mean
they're they're into the pipeline's
right and that a couple of months and
we'll be into the new year so we're
figuring that early in the new year will
have a much better idea statistically of
how many people are moving from trial to
permanent mods now let me say our
biggest concern of the program right now
there's making sure that as many people
as possible are able to convert to a
permanent modification are you using any
projections on this number surely
Treasury is doing its own modeling and
using some internal projections yes well
we had projections before the program
even started now we're we're interested
in or what are the actual rates so what
were your projections well the
projections were temporary to permanent
yeah the projections were very rough at
the
I'm it were they they were it depended
on the type of individual we're talking
about so it was a very complex set of
calculations that you had a number i
wouldn't go with any one number that we
have ranged numbers well as you know in
the past the rate of in different types
of programs where there weren't actual
deep reductions in expenses the rates
could be as low as fifty percent we were
expecting that because of the nature of
these modifications which have not been
done before in a large scale that is
where there are meaningful large
reductions in people's monthly payments
there if there aren't good statistics I
just haven't been designed the program
so you surely must have some model how
many people is Treasury projecting will
make it from these temporary short-term
modifications into a so-called permanent
modification well the estimate is is
significantly more than fifty percent
but I don't want to place overdue
emphasis on anyone know surely you are
using a model internally we're not using
a model that says significantly more
than reason is the reason is as you know
models are simply models and they don't
reflect Leo so I'm asking just a model
number the it was ranging up to
seventy-five percent somewhere between
50 and 75 okay but again the real issue
wasn't so painful well there was a real
issue for American because I don't want
to give overdue emphasis to any one
particular number because I think we can
focus on on the wrong thing really and
to engage in oversight we need to
understand your numbers and the
projections here so we can see if this
is working even on your assumptions the
real issue though is converting people
as as fully as possible to the permanent
modifications and that's why we're
taking these steps to try to make it
simpler now last week we brought in
again the main servicers in this program
and we sat down with them to focus on
the issue of trying to increase
conversion rates and maximizing those
and we've also told them that we're
going to start publishing service
metrics for the surfacers starting in
early December and they'll include
measures such as how long does it take
between the time that someone applies
for a modification in the time they
actually receive a permanent
modification how long does it take for
the servicers answer the phone and
provide answers to people who are very
concerned about whether they'll qualify
or not so we're trying to you'll be
naming names we will be naming names
will be naming individual banks against
the more than five of these different
service measures starting in early
December the banks are on notice and we
think by providing sunlight on the data
around services that these banks will
try even harder to meet the highest
standard thank you i look forward to it
extra pologize to both of you and i will
skip my next round of questions if need
be uh mr. Silver's thank you I I'm all
for thoroughness so no problem with me
assistant secretary Allison you've heard
a bit about mortgages I understand my
colleague superintendent Neiman's going
to talk to you a bit about small
business I would like to focus on very
big business yeah but don't take that as
a lack of interest in the other two
subjects just yesterday I think of a
little hard to tell the combination of
official announcements and leaks but it
appears that yesterday the the pay's are
Ken Feinberg announced a plan to require
that the law that the large the very
largest recipients of TARP funds cut
their executive pay significantly
particularly in relation to short the
cash component of that pay there have
been some anonymous quotes in the press
this morning from executives at these
firms pointing out that there's that a
lot of what mr. Feinberg has in mind is
to shift that pay toward long-term
compensation equity-based compensation
I hope you'll tell me if what I'm saying
is not true Lee I'm gleaning it from the
the published accounts the concern I
have about there's a concern i want you
to address about this which goes right
to the statement that have been made by
the Federal Reserve about the proper way
to do executive pay and financial
institutions on the one hand it appears
that mr. Feinberg is moving in the
direction of lengthening the time
horizons of pay and I think that's a
very good idea on the other hand I'm
very concerned and I would like you to
address the question of whether or not
we've got the risk element here properly
correct in the context of predicting the
context of banks with very low stock
prices that in pushing pay onto this ant
into equity form where this where the
stock price is low it's not clear these
folks really have that much downside
exposure and so as a result I'm
concerned that we are incentivizing a
certain amount of risk taking with the
public's money as a backstop and I
wonder if you could comment on that well
first of all as you know the Special
Master will soon be announcing his
comments compensation determinations and
will be explaining to the public how he
made those determinations so I'll leave
some of that explaining to him and he
has operated in a very independent way
he's making his own decisions but it is
important first of all that we protect
the interests of the taxpayers who have
invested so much of their money into
these companies over the past year and
so these these programs are being
designed in a way that will provide that
most of the pay will be long term in
nature some of the pay will be
conditioned on returning tarp money to
the taxpayers they're designed to
discourage excessive risk-taking at the
same time under the interim final rule
that governs the Special Master he's
encouraged to take it keep in mind the
need for the long-term survival and
competitiveness of these institutions in
the interest of taxpayers getting their
money back but also to make sure that
the pay is not excessive and take away
from the overall profitability of the
banks and their ability to rebuild
capital I guess my question my question
if you pay an executive of four I think
this problem is most severe at City and
potentially at aig depending on exactly
what the Special Master does if you pay
an executive at City city with a package
that is lettuce stock based primarily
the stock isn't for dollars right as i
believe it is roughly today there's just
not that much downside in that package
right and in that and what downside
there is is going to be absorbed frankly
by us by the public because when we all
know that if city takes large losses the
pressure to try to do something on the
part of the government will be profound
how what is your view now I know you're
not I know you're not the Special Master
but but you are in front of us today
what is your view as to how we avoid and
it sent a situation where those people
have all the upside of risk but none of
the downside well let me first of all
say that as you know the United States
government is a significant shareholder
in Citigroup and so what we're doing now
is aligning the interest of those
employees with the interest of taxpayers
and if the stock price of Citigroup does
go up the American taxpayer will benefit
as well I'm what about what happens if
it goes down because that because
there's no if you're thinking about this
from the prospect we have the downside
right they do not they being the
executives were incentivizing what what
do we I recognize it's not a simple
problem to solve and compensation design
but I want you to focus on it well sir
the the executives do have considered
with outside because as you mentioned
much of their pay is paid out over the
long term and is dependent upon
performance metrics including the stock
price in what you recognize don't do you
not that the downside for the executive
is capped at 0 at the value one of when
the value of the stock hits zero that's
as low as they can go we will take the
rest of it and it's it's the the full
value of all cities liabilities
potentially well first of all these
banks did undergo the stress test last
spring
they raised a considerable amount of
equity capital in fact the total raised
by the large banks was about 80 billion
dollars their capital positions are far
better today than they were then thanks
to the stress test initiated by the
secretary of the Treasury and conducted
by the Fed and other regulators so I
think the banks are in a much stronger
position today and we hope in a position
to start repaying the federal government
before too long my time has expired i'll
pass on thank you thank you mr niemann
thank you so so i would like to come
back to the initiatives to enhance and
promote small business lending that were
announced yesterday I was pleased to see
the inclusion of capital for smaller
community banks who provide a
substantial amount of credit to small
businesses I was particularly pleased to
see that the extension of that capital
community banks is contingent on a
submission of a business plan to
demonstrate the the amount and type of
lending where that lending would go to
support small businesses and that there
would be a follow-up requirement of
quarterly reporting detailing of those
lending transactions I think you
wouldn't be surprised that many of us
would have liked to have seen a similar
contingency and requirements earlier in
the CPP when that was announced by you
the prior administration there are a
number of questions that I think still
remain and many which i think you
acknowledge that the final decisions
that will take time as you roll out the
specifics of the program but but some of
the questions I have and there seems to
be some inconsistent reports in the
press as to are there in addition to the
three percent dividend are there other
charges for the capital that will be
provided to the banks for example will
there be the requirement of issuing
warrants there was a report in the
American Banker today that it would
include warrants well there is a de
minimis exception for issuing warrants
and the the exception is banks have
received less than a hundred million
dollars virtually every bank in this
program would be receiving less than a
hundred million dollars now these have
yet to be fully worked out we're going
to be issuing detailed guidance on this
program after we discuss the program
features with the banks as well as small
business but it is very likely that
these banks will not be subjected to the
same degree of a warrant requirement as
was in the case of cpp for the larger
banks for example now now one of the
other program provisions is modeled
after the CPP program that requires that
it be based on a determination that the
institution is deemed viable without the
capital right have you or the
administration considered modifying that
program to permit under certain
circumstances banks that would be deemed
to be viable after receipt of that
capital what we're what we're seeing and
what we've heard we've heard from others
is that in order to attract private
capital determination by the
administration that an institution is
not viable serves as a red-letter to
discourage a private capital so I'd be
interested if if you had considered
under certain circumstances it's my
understanding and in fact that FDR's
program did have its a specific
categories of those banks that would be
viable without and those banks that
would be viable only after a
contribution of capital yeah well first
of all we want to make sure that the
capital is used for the intention of the
program to stimulate lending and not
simply to fill a capital hole on the
bank's balance sheet that won't produce
additional lending and so we believe
that and we've considered this issue
very carefully commissioner Niemann
because we've been asked this question
many times and it's an important
question but we believe that this
program to be most effective should be
aimed at viable banks so they can use
the additional capital to promote
lending and with the additional capital
they can leverage that capital and lend
quite a bit more than the amount of the
capital itself secondly we have to of
course protect the interests of
taxpayers and so their interests are
better protected if we are lending to
viable banks and there are very large
number of these by the way this program
covers about ninety-one percent of all
the banks in America about 7500 banks so
it is a very broad program but we think
that for it to be most effective every
dollar of this additional capital should
go to additional lending so there was
internal discussion and analysis of
whether that viability test should be
reconsidered there was and it was there
the same analysis and discussion around
the 1 billion dollar cap should it be
increased to five billion dollars and
what you would pick up in turn or even
10 billion in terms of the contributions
to a small business lending we did
consider that very carefully for a
number of months actually and we
determined that because of the outsize
role that the small community banks
place not so small up to billion dollars
of assets because of their outside role
we think it's important to direct the
funding to them and they have the
highest rates of small business lending
of all the different segments of bank so
we think this is the best use of
taxpayers dollars to get this economy
rolling especially in communities all
across the country do you have an
estimation of the timing there's been a
clear you know level of concern around
the number of banks in the time it has
taken to what to process these
application do you expect that these
will be approved by the end of the year
or will it be determined it will be
dependent on whether the the tarp
program is is extended beyond the end of
the year well the good news is we have
the infrastructure for this program
already in place we don't have to build
it we can we can use the existing
capital purchase program infrastructure
we have the the procedures and the
policies largely in place already
so we can roll this program out very
rapidly we're anxious to get going we
want to meet with the bankers and small
business people just as soon as we can
to finalize the program and then get it
moving so we feel the sense of urgency
to roll this out right it's on the
timing of receipt of applications well
we want to begin to take the
applications very soon I can't give you
an exact date when we'll be doing that
but we'll be announcing that very
shortly thank you thank you thank you
okay I'm still on the hunt for some
numbers on foreclosure so I what I make
sure I understand is we talked about the
HAMP program 500,000 people into it by
mid-october we raised the question about
whether or not this will be enough to
slow down the rate of foreclosures so
that we can get some stabilization in
the housing market we then asked of the
people who come in the 500,000 just to
use that example of the people who come
into the program how many will make it
into permanent modifications and you
said somewhere between a quarter and a
half are unlikely to so I want to ask
the next part and that is of the people
who make it into so-called permanent
modifications water Treasuries
projections on how many people will
actually be able to make those payments
and still be in those houses at the end
of the five-year period and make the
transition back into their permanent
mortgages in other words the question I
just want to draw is fine a point on it
as I can are we preventing foreclosures
or are we simply delaying them yeah well
first of all I'd like to correct the
record on this I did not say that we
expect that one quarter to a half will
not be converted there that was our 50
to 75 percent success rate I was doing
the math the other was saying was that
we had looked at some modeling last
winter and early spring in fact it was
before I arrived okay to try to estimate
the size of this program but we're
interested now that we're actually
operating and growing very rapidly is
looking at the actual conversion rates
and trying to maximize those as much as
possible so I of course paired to say
what we think the rate will be of
successful conversions all I can say is
that we'll have much better information
and much better estimates based on real
experience by early in the first quarter
but you are also not telling me that
Treasury is flying here with no
projections on how this program works in
terms of numbers you can't be telling me
that there must be projections on how
this program will work well we projected
is that we'll be able to do within the
three-year period of this program when
we're actively bringing people in and
modifying mortgages we expect to be able
to succeed with about three to four
million people ok so right which is a
very large portion we also believe
already given the eligible population of
people for this program today that were
about keeping pace at least and maybe
ahead of the foreclosure rate for that
population so you don't mean foreclosure
filings you mean because the Persian
filings are accelerating is what the
rate would be without this program well
ok and so I think we're making
tremendous progress now we're not
satisfied with the with the place we're
at today we're working with the
servicers to increase as much as
possible the rate of trial modification
some banks still have a long way to go
to reach their eligible populations here
we want them to move as rapidly as
possible and then the challenge is going
to be and you're absolutely right and we
are very concerned about this the
challenge is to minimize the failure
rate of getting people from a trial
modification to an actual modification
so let me ask so that I don't have to
run four minutes over again ok what
projection is Treasury using for the
proportion of homeowners who will be
able to make it from a trial
modification to a permanent modification
well again we would like to we would
like to have as many people as possible
and it may be you know if we if we were
to it I would like all the children to
be above average but that's not the
world we live in you must have a
projection here
what I'm trying to say is i think if we
can get this rate to something like
three quarters that is a very ambitious
success rate so are you telling me that
that's what you're projecting is you're
working this program out you must have a
projection for what number you're using
for the conversion rate from temporary
modifications to permanent modifications
Treasury must this is you can't have a
program for which you're not projecting
how many people will be in it and how
many will begin at each stage so the
question I'm asking is what is your
projection on the proportion that will
make it from temporary modifications to
permanent modifications so that we can
evaluate this program whether or not
it's likely big enough to deal with the
problem right again based on past
experience with different types of
modifications which were not materially
reducing people's monthly payments you
saw a failure rate of about fifty
percent so we could use that as a bare
minimum success rate but we like to
achieve a much higher rate if we were to
get to something like 75 which is an
aspiration we would deem this quite a
successful person so I just want to make
sure I'm understanding the projection is
the floor will be that you'll have at
least fifty percent of those who get
into a trial modification will make it
I'm sorry did the wrong one fifty
percent of those who make it into a
permanent modification will actually be
able to make their mortgage payments for
five years no I know what I'm saying is
we we would say that the bare minimum of
getting from a trial mod to an actual
mod okay should be above and then the
failure rate and then I'm sorry and I I
also confused it yes I could use it yeah
I Rida fault rate the rate at which
those people who get these so-called
permanent modifications actually stay in
their homes for at least five years and
we are not simply delaying foreclosures
we're actually preventing them what's
the right there how many people who make
it to to permanent modifications does
Treasury anticipate will actually be
able to pay those mortgages well I think
there again there isn't a good past set
of evidence for a program like this all
right because what is so important about
the program is that we're materially
reducing people I understand and I we
the panel has been quite complimentary
about the approach the the question is
what's the number you're using in your
projection of those who make it to
permanent modifications what proportion
in fact we'll still end up in
foreclosure well I we're really not sure
what proportion it must have a
projection you must be we all have hoped
it numbers we've been looking at numbers
now for a year in terms of what are
called Rida fault rates that is people
who got a modification and then it
doesn't work yeah you must have a
projection for this Treasury has put
this program forward what's the
projection you're using based on all the
data you've read I understand the
programs are different i understand
there are lots of different studies that
use lots of different information right
what's your projection well i think
again what what i can do is to come back
to the to the panel with our best
estimate on what that might be all right
but i think again our goal is to get
beyond the projections to reach real
Americans who were in trouble and try to
have as many of them succeed in this
program as possible it's that I'm sure
that's everyone's goal um mr. Silver's
this is secretary Allison can you um
tell us how long what is the dollar
amount assigned to the small business
program we were discussing with
superintendent Neiman a moment ago well
at this point we are going to be working
with the with the communities that are
going to be helped by this program to
try to estimate the take-up rate for it
so we will be in a better position to
estimate for you what the actual
expenditure might be once we've
completed that work because we're going
to try to tailor the program as much as
we can to the actual needs instead of
designing the program in the abstract
and finalizing every aspect of it then
rolling it out we've announced the broad
metrics of the program and now we want
to work with them to see how we can
maximize the take up and then we'll be
able to give you a better estimate we
are using tarp money here right yes we
are right so this it can't be more than
the amount of
a tarp money for sanity correct can you
give me any further insight into your
thinking as to what the range might be I
don't want to get into a 10 minute
discussion of it but I I'm interested
yeah can you scale it for me in any
respect yeah well it's it would be a
fraction of the amount of remaining
money I would say would be somewhere
between ten billion dollars and as much
as fifty billion dollars that's that's
very helpful the answer could be
somewhere in between again we want to do
responsibly here with the using
taxpayers money is to provide as
accurate an estimate as possible I see
there have been some suggestions I
believe senator Warner in particular
suggested the idea of essentially as we
have done in some of the credit markets
just effectively bypassing the bank
credit system and moving tarp money
directly to small business with with
private sector managers yes right can
you explain to me why you thought you
peered have decided to go this route
instead of master yeah we've decided to
go through the community banks because
we think that's by far the most
effective and efficient way of reaching
large numbers of small businesses
because these banks already have
relationships with these companies
throughout the country oh yeah no I
that's not the question I think the
postal senator Warner had was actually
to you to go through those same banks
the HD issue was whether or not the way
you're where you're proposing to do it
is you're going to give the bank's some
equity capital and then they're going to
give you a plan for how they're going to
lend you assume that money plus other
money to small business it's actually if
I may say it's in Reverse they're going
to give us the plan then we're gonna
member I didn't I didn't I wasn't
implying an order the Alta you had you
have to have a certain confidence that
they're actually going to do that and
not as you suggested your concern might
be that they were going to fill capital
holes and the like on the other hand if
you did what you did what what was done
with tarp in the more in more
financialized markets which was to go
directly into those markets right in the
towel program I see right you know the
senator Warner was talking about it
going directly into the small business
landing market hiring the community
banks to manage it for you but that
thereby ensuring that the money in fact
ended up where you want it to end up I'm
just curious that you made a choice to
to you to you to to use the bank's
capital structure not just their
managerial capacity but their capital
struct right and the reason is because
by providing capital they can leverage
the capital to do much more lemming
right perhaps eight to ten times the
amount of the capital candyland so your
hope is that for example just take a
number that if you put 25 million into
this that you might be able to generate
between one and two hundred billion
dollars of nuts that's correct yes about
that's the whole track well that's yes I
thought I think that's very thoughtful
okay the let me let me let me shift back
for a moment to big business why not
when when our last round ended you were
telling me about the the perception that
Treasury belief of the growing strength
of the large banking sector if I'm
curious if each of wells fargo city & B
of A showed up this morning with a check
for the balance of their tarp funds
would you accept it well first of all
that's really a matter for the
regulators to determine first of all
because they're responsible for the
financial soundness of those
institutions all right my personally I
hope you would correct me if I'm wrong
my perception is that at least Wells
Fargo of those three banks has almost
begged in public to be allowed to return
the money and which suggests that
they've got the check and yet they're
not being allowed to return it why would
why in your view was that so again I
wouldn't speak for the regulators of
Wells Fargo so I would defer to them and
their determination of whether wells
fargo was ready to repay obviously on
behalf of the taxpayers we'd be
delighted to receive our money back from
these banks but we also have to
recognize that the money was put out
there
to enhance financial stability the
regulators are far better qualified in
the US Treasury Department as to when
those banks will be able to repay um if
I can ask the indulgence of fellow
panelists justjust expressive final
thought here it seems to me that you are
it seems to me that you and the
regulators and are behaving wisely here
that that that this is the real test of
whether or not these we have salt we
have repaired our large our large
financial institutions is whether or not
in the privacy of whatever rooms that
these decisions are made people fully
informed individuals presumably acting
in good in good faith with the public
interest in mind are willing to allow
these banks to return the money and I
think the decision the evident fact that
they have not returned the money
suggests that in truth there's not a
comfort level with doing that I think
that's very good i would urge you not to
submit to any kind of pressure to allow
banks that are fundamentally not yet
sound to return the money but i think it
raises a larger issue which which goes
back to the you know my concerns of my
opening statement and to the backdrop to
your views about the weakness of the
small business lending market and to the
backdrop to the sort of endgame around
mortgages which is these institutions do
not appear to get to really be healthy
and that's a very dangerous thing given
the size of those institutions and it
seems to me that that you know that that
is a that remains a continuing challenge
mr. Silver's first of all these banks
have raised large amounts of capital
some cases very large amounts of capital
since last spring since the stress tests
they are far better capitalized and they
were then and so they're in a better
position to begin considering i think
repayment but the regulators have to be
the the arbiters of the
and of course we're in dialogue with
with the regulators as well and so I
wouldn't characterize these banks as
being impaired today I think they're far
healthier than they were before and
they've made a number of to take a
number of steps to reduce risk on their
balance sheets as well so i think the
day is nearing when they'll be able to
begin repaying certainly a lot closer
than it was last spring my time is far
expired mr. Neiman so I had intended to
use this round of questionings to focus
on conversion rates from trial mods to
the permanence and ray defaults but
considering the time we spent on that I
just make a few points that you know in
my additional views in the October
report you know I did note that it was
in my opinion was too early to calculate
those conversions and because of the
very low statistics could could be
skewed for for a number of reasons
however I think those kinds of
projections would be helpful and they're
already Press reports be of a has been
reported in the New York Times that they
have estimated a fifty percent
conversion rate so I was going to frame
my my question that it would be helpful
to Treasury to provide its own guidance
and I question was going to be when do
you expect to be in a position to to
project conversion rates and Rida fault
rates and ongoing of volumes for help
yeah first of all again we're trying to
continually improve this program to
increase the conversion rates and we are
going to be as I mentioned before in a
better position to estimate what the
goals for conversion should be when we
have further experience and have made
further improvements in the program and
that should be early in the first
quarter and I think we'll be revising
those those estimates as we go forward
gain more experience and provide further
improvements to the program now also in
the October report and you responded
briefly to the issue in your
testimony you know we pointed out that
the administration's housing foreclosure
prevention program was designed six to
eight months ago when and ago an
unemployment has continued to grow since
then and the end the and the crisis has
certainly extended and foreclosures
extended from subprime into prime so my
question is really focusing on what is
the Treasury doing on the issue of
targeted foreclosure relief for the
recently unemployed I've suggested both
in our last report and other meetings
with you and personally with the
secretary to explore a federal funding
for state programs that are modeled
after Pennsylvania's successful program
AHIMA program housing emergency mortgage
assistance a program that provides in a
sense short-term a secured bridge loans
for people who are recently unemployed a
program of this nature could be funded
either possibly through tarp or through
legislation so my question is is there a
reason not to pursue this approach to
explore whether tarp or legislative
proposals which is my understanding
there are some that have been proposed
on the hill should not be pursued as
part of the administration's program we
are familiar with the Pennsylvania
program and we have high regard for
what's been done in Pennsylvania and a
number of other states have initiated
the foreclosure prevention measures as
well let me mention again that our own
program now allows people to qualify who
have expected unemployment payments for
at least nine months to come we are
still studying what more we might do in
that area we think that our program as
is designed today is the most efficient
one to reach a large number of people
and also to protect taxpayer dollars at
the same time but we're open to
suggestions as we have been all along we
are looking further at the Pennsylvania
model as well to see what more might be
done Saudi let me also mention that
there are other again other federal
programs underway
such as for State Housing Finance
agencies for cities or other areas that
are impacted more than average already
these programs are in place so we can't
look just at the HAMP program as the as
the total they also mention that outside
of the the tarp program the
government-sponsored entities Freddie
Mac and Fannie Mae also have their own
program which is identical to ours to
reach their borrowers as well well to
the extent that the analysis around that
program continues and a decision is made
one way or another I would appreciate it
if you would get back to our panel once
a decision or provide us any analysis or
decisioning around it thank you we will
thank you actually I want to start by
following up on on the previous two
lines of question I just want to make
sure and following on mr. Silver's
question as I understand it in the small
business lending you'll be asking the
the banks to propose plans for using
this money which is substantial advance
over where we were a year ago but I just
want to make sure unlike the tarp
funding for the big banks a year ago
this time will we be tracking the money
okay well first of all with the program
that already exists the capital purchase
program we have luminous information on
our website financial stability gov
about the actual lending by all these
banks and we think it's very important
that the public be able to see for
themselves what's really important is
how much lending are they doing we also
have indications that this program has
been quite successful in producing
lending rates in the banks that are
higher than they would have been without
the program so we think we're being
quite transparent about actual lending
activity and so for this program as well
we want to be reporting on the actual
lending being done by these banks I that
was that was all my question and what in
terms of tracking how the money is being
utilized
we're asking the banks they'll be taking
part in this program to give us their
goals and we'll be looking at their
goals and then we'll be measuring the
performance in for instance and lending
which is the main objective of the
program in a way that the American
public can judge for themselves how each
of these banks is performed so so we
will be verifying that they use the tax
dollars for small business lending
they'll be verified I get their lending
rates before they take the money correct
and we should expect to see essentially
exactly right either a dollar for dollar
improvement in their lending or with
leverage from private investment a
better than dollar for dollar improving
almost landing absolutely we hope there
is a better than dollars a dollar but I
think the important point is to judge
them against the plans that that they
submit as to how much additional lending
they're doing which should be more than
the dollars were putting into the bank's
all right and we'll be documenting yes
ma'am that that sounds good that sounds
very good thank you all right and let me
ask a follow-up to mr. Neiman's question
we're talking about all these programs
the the various programs some obviously
underway on mortgage foreclosure
mitigation as some perhaps in the wings
to try to deal with the problem I just
want to ask about the other half these
are all questions about using taxpayer
money in order to bail out homeowners
and in particular the investors who
bought those mortgages who invested in
those mortgages for high profits how
much are we talking about programs where
the investors have to acknowledge their
losses and come to the economically
rational place in dealing with
foreclosures I worry about the fact to
fax the evidence suggests that a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars is lost in
every mortgage foreclosure that would
seem to me to be an enormous incentive
for the mortgage lenders themselves
frankly with no government help to come
in and modify those mortgages but the
second part is for every dollar of
federal money that goes in and
ultimately makes it into
hands of the mortgage lenders there's an
increased incentive for them to sit on
the sidelines and hope that more federal
dollars are coming and not come to the
table and negotiate with their
homeowners so I just want to hear about
the part of the program that encourages
the lenders to acknowledge their losses
rather than then taxpayers having to
pick that up first of all as you point
out foreclosure is very expensive it's
expensive to everybody to the homeowner
as well as to the original lender we
believe that our program which is
designed for situations in which there
is a positive net present value to
modifying the mortgage has caused banks
to take a hard look at whether they
might be better off by modifying the
mortgage and as the principal relief
which is your other question what are we
doing about that The Making Home
Affordable program does allow for
principal relief does provide the same
types of incentives we also have now
coupled the hope for homeowners program
which involves principal relief into our
waterfall of alternatives and the folks
who run the h4h program are working on
revised rules that I'd instead will soon
be rolled out for that program so we
should see more activity in the help for
homeowners program as well in addition
the Obama administration has long
advocated responsible reform of
bankruptcy rules to provide to bring
lenders together with borrowers to try
to prevent bankruptcy which is expensive
to all sides by negotiating an
affordable modification in those places
Thank You mr. Silver's I want to pick up
on this line of questioning a little bit
we as a superintendent neiman mentioned
we had hearing in Philadelphia and your
office is very helpful providing
witnesses at that hearing we there was
great deal of focus on these two issues
you just mentioned
the question of negative equity and the
reform of our bankruptcy laws on the one
hand and secondly the the issue of the
unemployed and in respect to the reform
of the bankruptcy laws and I just draw
this to your attention it was knowledge
by several by the our witness our expert
witness from the Federal Reserve Bank in
Boston that really the bankruptcy would
reform was the only was the only way
anybody could think of to target relief
in the area of negative equity right
that although that there's a problem if
you just throw money at negative equity
that it goes to lots of people can
actually afford to pay their mortgages
right but that but that if a bankruptcy
process there's a there's a gate keep
this a kind of gatekeeper mechanism
their bankruptcies unpleasant and has
real consequences for the person going
bankrupt but your target to the leaf
that way secondly when I come back to
unemployment there there was a
near-universal I think actually
Universal view among our witnesses that
the treasury's programs did not
adequately address the unemployment
driven foreclosure wave and as
superintendent Neiman suggested a deep
interest in the he map program the
Pennsylvania program do I take from your
testimony I want to be clear that you
are looking at further actions in this
area is that it might be am i hearing
your testimony right we've been looking
at a wide variety of actions including
to help people who are unemployed as I
mentioned that this program now makes it
possible for people who have the
prospect of another nine months or more
of unemployment insurance to take part
in the program and will continue to look
at what else we might do and in
balancing the interests of the taxpayers
with the needs the very serious needs of
people who become unemployed and we are
looking at various models I'm not
committing
that will will be able to instigate any
particular method at this point I didn't
hardly looking at but you are actively
looking absolutely i mean i would urge i
don't i think you know this but i would
i would urge you to not just consider
this as a balance between the interests
of the taxpayers and the interests of
people facing unemployment and
foreclosure but the systemic
consequences of the unemployment driven
foreclosure wave this is a very serious
problem the obama administration takes
it very seriously it's it's initiated
wide variety of measures again beyond
the HAMP program the entire economic
stimulus program is intended to create
jobs and to preserve jobs as much as
possible during the most serious
recession we've had in at least 50 years
you know I we at least I personally am
aware and supportive of a much of that
of the much of that work I think that
the particular program of unemployment
particular problem of unemployment
driven foreclosures is one that I think
was underestimated through no one's
particular fault early on in the
development of The Making Home
Affordable program and I'm glad to hear
that you're looking at further what
options are available i urge you to do
that thank you and we certainly
understand the importance of this issue
very good i want to then turn back to
the small business peace for a moment
the there's a trade-off it seems to me
between the strategy you have taken
there's a trade-off between the
potential of leveraging of leveraging
small business lending versus the
certainty of a direct our pipeline right
that you'd be pretty to be certain that
that money was going to small business
lending if you did it directly i think
that i would i would urge you to sort of
focus on our chairs comments about the
need given the choice you've made to two
very two very closely monitor not not
just the plan at the front end but the
implementation of the plan at the back
end from these banks so i just want
wanted to thank you and and we fully
agree with you okay very good i'll stop
here on pass on to my colleague mr.
Neiman
thank you you know I want to focus on
the stress test and you know pick up on
commercial real estate blending which we
really haven't touched on yet the stress
test required that the largest banks to
carry and in some cases raise additional
regulatory capital when those tests were
conducted last spring many of the
conservatives concerns revolved around
the market mark marked to market
securities now it appears that those
securities may have stabilized somewhat
and now the concerns have really shifted
to portfolio loans on banks balance
sheets particularly commercial real
estate is your office looking at or
considering any programs other than P
pip and talth for Percy MBS programs
commercial mortgage-backed securities or
an expansion of those programs to
address the particular issues around
commercial real estate loans let me say
that we've looked at many alternatives
this is a problem that is considerable
across the country both because the
securitization markets are not as robust
as they were before and because banks
have a large amount of commercial real
estate loans on their books in fact the
smaller banks tend to have a larger
proportion of commercial real estate on
their books then do the bigger banks
that's another reason why we've launched
this program aimed at community banks
which have a lot of their small business
lending is connected with commercial
real estate lending as well so by
providing them access to additional
capital we can help them to withstand a
deterioration in the value of those
assets on their books now we think that
providing capital is more efficient and
more effective than drawing directly
intervene to support prices in the
commercial real estate market which
would be very expensive and really
impractical so by providing capital the
banks are better able to deal with the
problems on their books by for instance
extending loans or modifying loans over
time and we think that they're already
there's a lot of creativity in the
commercial real estate market some
investors are coming in we're seeing
someone
more activity in the securitization
markets in pockets and banks earnings
also can help them to withstand this
problem over the next several years so i
think the banks are well aware of the
problem as are the regulators and
they're working actively to deal with it
are there any proposals around
addressing the commercial real estate
problem that you could share with us
particularly problems of projects that
support affordable housing multi-family
housing there are a great concern in
many urban areas including New York that
large commercial lenders who use those
funds to purchase a low and medium
medium income housing projects now that
they are facing a possible defaults are
cutting back on maintenance and services
and is becoming a real community concern
are there any programs that you can
share with us today that may have some
level of real interest to confirm that
there are programs under consideration
well we have been in dialogues with
community leaders and also with Housing
Finance agencies and others to to look
at this problem and and so overall there
have been measures taken to support the
Housing Finance agencies and the work
with them on this problem and as you
know there are different situations for
different housing projects and in some
cases the banks are stepping into to
deal with this or other in new investors
as well so there variety of ways of
dealing with that problem and but again
right now our focus is going to be on
providing capital to the community banks
to help them deal with a very widespread
issue of commercial real estate and
supporting small business and those two
are intertwined and the communities
across the country still on the on the
stress test is there any consideration
being given to rerunning any of those
stress tests on large or regional banks
with a particular focus on commercial
real estate loans and to extend the time
horizon on those tests out another year
you know we certainly have utilized and
I've said publicly in New York we've
utilized stress tests on an ad hoc basis
in situations where we feel a bank may
have may have may have issues but is
there any consideration we've
recommended it in past reports that the
administration and then the regulator's
consider expanding out either on a ad
hoc or systemic basis the stress test as
you know the regulators are very well
aware of these issues and they are the
ones who determine how to stress test
those institutions and I'm sure that
they've had extensive dialogues through
their supervisors with these banks to
understand what their situation really
is okay thank you my time is expired all
right I I'd like to ask some questions
about the winding down I was interested
to see that on sep tember 18th uh the
money market guarantees were permitted
to expire is the guarantee really gone
the next time money market managers face
big losses and the money market account
breaks the buck of is there anyone in
America who doesn't believe that the
American government will rush back in
and support the money markets well first
of all the need for that program went
away well it's going to wait for today
I'm asking about tomorrow the next time
we hit a financial crisis so do we have
in effect the question I'm asking them
do we have an effect of free guarantee
out there that is we won't call it a
guarantee in boom times and when there's
a bust then we'll move in so unlike FDIC
insurance for example which you have to
pay for all the time it's just a an
insurance policy that you pay for only
when you're sick yeah well that's
another reason why the administration
has been proposing comprehensive reform
of the financial industry and also
adequate disclosure by institutions
about their financial situations so I
think that you know the question that
you're asking is there a moral hazard
they design here the intention of the
administration's programs is to to
reduce drastically the need for federal
intervention going forward through
regulatory reform absolutely right so
let me ask you another one and we'll
we'll see PP CA P and T IP I am learning
the acronyms of Washington well those
three programs be closed by the end of
the year let me just mention as the
capital purchase program capital access
program and the and the program for just
a few bags at CIAT IP and show off oh
that's the trouble investment program
but those those programs are in effect
going away they're being Tippett they
will be gone by the end of the year at
the end of the year are we planning any
new programs to launch the programs that
are planned are the ones that talked
about today okay so that means that
going forward just if you could describe
what tarp will be starting in January
what what's left there'll be well we
have the homeowners program first to the
homeowners program will be ongoings that
the new cell business little Bank
program absolutely and others will still
have the investments that we've made
that have not yet been repaid but surely
we don't need a whole tarp apparatus to
be stocking actually we're gonna we're
going to need people who are looking
after those assets asset managers as
well as accountants I'm actually sorry
to hear that we're still not considering
the panel recommendation to put those
shares of stock and trust i should say
treasury is still not considering the
panel's recommendation to put the shares
of stock of the auto industry and the
large financial institutions in trust
most of most of our holdings are in
preferred stock we are where's common
stockholders in a few companies and end
and the recommendation is to take our
common stock and put it in trust the ISA
law under the emergency economic
stimulation act right stimulus act we
the Treasury secretary has the
responsibility for overseeing those
investments he cannot shed that
responsibility even if he put them in a
trust or a limited liability company the
Treasury secretary still has that
responsibility under the law I'm sorry
I'm not quite understanding are you
saying it's not lawful for this
Secretary of Treasury to put the shares
of stock in Chrysler and GM into trust
no I'm not I'm saying that even if they
are put into a trust vehicle or a
limited liability company the Treasury
Secretary still has the responsibility
for the for overseeing those assets it's
possible to do that the question is
whether that's an efficient use of
taxpayers dollars to create that
administrative infrastructure since the
Treasury secretary still has the
responsibility for oversight all right
good I'm going to quit early this time
mr. Silver's thank you I want to circle
back to where we started about executive
pay thinking about this it seems to me
that this week we have seen a fair
amount of public anger about bonuses in
the financial sector most of which are
actually not to top executives and most
of which are across a number of firms
not all of which will be subject to mr.
Feinberg's recommendations so what would
what do you say to the public all right
who are who say we're expressing the
view that firms like JPMorgan Goldman
Sachs Morgan Stanley are alive today
because of the combination of cpp funds
and and federal reserve dollars that
they have now handed out vast sums to a
relatively small number of people sums
that would simply not have been there
absent government support
and they are not going to be affected by
mr. Feinberg's recommendations because
they apply only to the banks will be
discussing earlier what what do we tell
the public yeah well the administration
and the Treasury secretary have been
outspoken about the need for financial
institutions to structure their
compensation in ways that promote a
long-term view for the health of those
companies and responsible risk-taking
and obviously the public is angry about
the pay levels in the financial industry
amongst some institutions not all by any
means and I'm sure that the boards and
the management's of those institutions
must be aware of this we have also as
you know impose the interim final rule
on the institution's receiving special
assistance from the federal government
and the results of those determinations
will be out very shortly other banks
that are still in the capital purchase
program for instance and these other
programs that we mentioned are still
subject to the to the rules that govern
those companies on compensation as well
and what we need is comprehensive reform
of financial institutions of the
regulations that cover them and boards
have to be responsible and making sure
that their pay programs are reasonable
that are paying for real economic
performance and not just the spirts in
market prices and that they're in
incenting their employees to think about
the long-term and to manage risks
responsibly it seems to me that in
respect to the bonuses that we just
announced the horses left the barn and
my question is with the administration
consider looking at tax policy as a way
of roping that horse well I'm sure that
the Congress and the administration are
equally concerned about about this but i
can't speak for tax policy some of your
colleagues at Treasury you might want to
have a chat
I'm sure that others will have more to
say about this let me move from that
this earlier this week Neil Barofsky
issued his report as the Special
Inspector General he raised an issue
about his report talked about a sort of
confidence deficit or something of the
like I forget the exact term he used and
he cited particularly the statements
made by your predecessors about the fact
that all the banks that were getting CPP
money were healthy and that that was
clearly not true we I have noted in the
past that I think one of the
achievements of your team and secretary
Geithner was to reverse that position
that the stress tests were effectively
reversal of that I wanted I would like
you to address other what other steps
you are taking to shall we say reverse
this confidence deficit and with
particular reference to what plans you
have to be forthcoming about the destiny
of these large banks that were the
subject of this essentially
misrepresentation according to mr.
barofsky around their health well first
thing they made clear that as we
expressed in a letter I sent to mr.
barofsky some time ago we fully share
his concern that the government operated
with transparency and accountability and
that's guided us during this
administration and we have published by
luminous information about the tarp
program on our website national
stability gov about the lending
practices of the banks about every
transaction that we've done about the
models we use and valuing warrants and
valuing our investments we're going to
be reporting a full accounting of the
value of these investments by the end of
this year so that the public can see for
themselves what the returns have been on
the money they've invested through tarp
so we're trying to be as as open as
possible I have dialogues with mr.
Barofsky every week and sometimes more
than one week like this week we've met
several times and we are I think share
the same goal to try to protect the
interests of taxpayer
while also promoting financial stability
and we have adopted at least
three-fourths of the of the Special
Inspector General's recommendations as
we have your own recommendations which
we welcome and the GAO and the financial
stability Oversight Council so we are
trying to be as open and responsive as
we can possibly be we understand our
substantial responsibility to the
American public Oh mr. Neiman up our to
give you a heads up for our future
reports yeah our December report we're
going to look back over the last 12
months and really look at how effective
what are the measurements what are the
metrics that we should be looking at
what measurements the American taxpayer
should be looking at to see the state of
the economy and the effectiveness of the
Treasury's program and credit
availability will be an important part
of that analysis and as you know though
measuring credit availability in this
environment is very complex and we know
that credit contracts in a recession as
banks and consumers deleverage and we
know that underwriting standards become
tighter as banks strive to conserve
capital so you know I'm looking to you
as to as we grapple with this question
what should the the American taxpayer
how should they be assessing the
effectiveness of the of the Treasury's
programs to promote a bank lending
should they be looking at credit spreads
or Bank origination levels or portfolio
holdings what would be helpful and
meaningful for for the American
taxpayers thanks for your question
actually we do a lot of thinking and
work on that subject we have many
different measures that we use to assess
the effectiveness of these programs and
also the activity in the financial
markets and would be glad by the way to
sit down with members of your staff to
go over our metrics as well as you
produce your own report but I have to
say that
for all the measures of debt spreads and
prices and and what-have-you capital
ratios what counts to the American
public eventually is going to be if the
job market getting better can I afford
to stay in my home is our businesses
able to get credit and even though these
programs have helped to alleviate these
problems we're not by any means
satisfied and we have to keep on
striving to to make these programs as
relevant and is useful to the American
public and produce real results as
possible and that's why we're altering
the thrust of the tarp program today
from having helped the large financial
institutions survive which was important
to the financial system given their role
but now get into what's happening with
the but the American public into small
businesses get capital can small banks
be be helpful and can people to stay in
their homes so that's where we're
focusing our effort today so we can give
you the financial metrics the more
sophisticated measures that we use but I
think ultimately these programs will be
judged by their impact on the American
economy as felt by the American public
are there any plans to expand the
monthly lending snapshot I know you've
extended it beyond the the largest 19 to
include 200 banks though it is a monthly
snapshot i I've been recommending for a
while that it should include trend
information comparisons to earlier
periods such as 2006 when credit was
running high and even the fall of 08
when credit markets were frozen I and I
think that would give those kind of
trends would provide perspective for for
the American public as to where we are
in comparison to where we were I think
that's a great suggestion let's see what
we can do there great thank you
mr. assistant secretary thank you very
much thank you for your time thank you
for your service we appreciate your
coming here today the record will remain
open for questions additional questions
from the panel and from our members who
couldn't be here today and with that
this hearing is adjourned thank you very
much
you